welcome to this video Grandmaster less
leshy leshy uh Brian Smith okay that
that's a recent um he only recently got
the Grandma's title
let's see yeah we have a rui
speaking to my
gun so to speak
okay okay let's let's play this this old
favorite of mine the
good old
chigoren
okay now this is quick D5 is of course
um a viable line but for my intentions
it's um nothing very scary because I I
play this kind of regrouping
um in any case with the Knight traveling
um to dhf7 and so on
um maybe I can play differently here
I wonder
what if I play like that
and then do the regrouping
so that if he takes on B5 I actually am
on the a file this is an interesting way
to play
and we'll continue with this I know it
looks maybe weird if you have not seen
it before but it does make some sense to
play like that
you get um you get good the good good
nights on the on the king side to to
cover your to cover your um your king
okay so he's going for this space Gainer
on them
on the king side with G4 white can also
exactly play with a quick F4
okay so I'm going to take this and maybe
try for Bishop H6 if possible he's not
preventing that hmm
okay
maybe you can play G5 afterwards
oh maybe
maybe he can
hmm yeah my rook's a little bit offside
okay I'm going to try it anyway but um I
have some doubts here
yeah we can play combinations of G5 and
E5 and this looks a bit dangerous
I'm only I'm hoping that he's playing a
somewhat
somewhat less forcing continuation
I'm worried about G5 takes them this is
what I was hoping that I mean not not
that I'm sure that this is great but
at least this is not an immediate threat
to my to my position
oh that's uh that's surprising
he keeps us closed okay let's make sure
that there are more pawns on light
squares
then get the queen over
let's see Knight to E5 possibly
I have a pretty solid blockade now on E5
and G5
and under the right circumstance I can
and can do something on the king side
with H5 but only the circumstances must
be really really right
it's not not easy to to accomplish
if I go Knight G7 here hmm probably will
move it tonight
okay let's put this on E5
yeah okay after that I have no problems
whatsoever I guess
because the only way now for him to um
to make any Headway is a peace sacrifice
like
Knight H5 Knight F5 he has a dead Bishop
him
so I don't really think that this is a
huge
a huge issue
um Pawn to G5 could be could be an issue
oh okay
okay I know that the Knight on G7 looks
a bit stupid but I need to have Rook
evade I want to play Queen H4
also
at the moment G5 I'm just going to take
H3 so this is not not a problem
strategically speaking G5 is a threat
from from White point of viewing it
would allow him to play Bishop D1 to G4
okay yeah I'm now Queen H4
again preventing
this this idea of playing G5 as H3 hangs
yeah one one very uh little detail is
that
it might be possible for Me Maybe I'm
not sure about it
it might be possible for me if we X
trade everything yeah except
we trade everything except lights and
minor pieces yeah it might be possible
for me to get to win the A5 Pawn
it's a bit a bit funny but maybe it's
possible
okay if I tick now
um now H5 is also
but Queen H6 looks looks a bit tricky
okay
it's okay and play Rook f8 next
G5 Rook f8 is also and maybe you can do
that maybe G5 now
hmm
you should play G5 now I think
to really make sure it's not getting
into any trouble
there are some chances in this end game
for black getting the A5 Pawn
it's it's totally isolated from the rest
of White's camp
it's taking time he will play G5 no he's
not playing G5
that's that's surprising
yeah okay well this is this is also a
move I can take 98
yeah he will always get get some play
against the D6 Pawn
this is probably I can try this
and then you can go G5 actually
it's not mattering very much
yeah I wonder he can still go G5
I should try to prevent that for the
time being
yeah where is there a way actually to
get to the to the B7 Square
only if I am probably not yeah
okay what I have to do in any case is I
need to trade Rooks so
I'm going to go for that
maybe I can go via H6 f78 this kind of
this kind of route
yeah that's possible
let's think about it
I need to go via maybe I should go here
in H5 first actually
that's also a good idea
H5
times takes takes
hmm
okay
so there is a way to be seven
and it's it's like this
H6 F7
um
let's prevent the Knight coming to F6
yeah yeah I'm on my way to B7
yeah he's got the Knight to F5 here for
counter play
probably it's best to grab
now is this
ah he's got this counter play but okay
I'm getting B3 as well so the a pawn
will run
um um
how do I do that actually
let's go over here
and if he plays
G7 I play King F7
check
white forfeits on time yeah I sped up at
the right moment yeah I think he um
he underestimated maybe the whole idea I
mean for a long time it was certainly
still all right for white
but um yeah he's really the only one
with with the problem here because of
the A5 Pawn
and he he didn't address it in in some
way I was thinking that if he goes here
after Queen E7 he should just play G5
and after that it's basically over
I mean I mean in terms of winning for
black or doing anything because then I
never get to age six you have to
understand that the only route to A5 is
wire B7 which means Y8 via F7 wire H6 so
you have to control H6 to protect your
A5 Pawn it's a bit a bit weird but
that's the way it is done and here after
Rook f8 if we get this kind of position
check we are just heading to a total
draw I mean it's it's totally closed up
and there is no way forward here
um I cannot
I cannot do that right no I was thinking
maybe H6 at some point but I will never
ever going to I'm not able to do that
and so this is just a total draw
G5 would have um would have guaranteed
why the draw
and maybe maybe the game continuation as
well but here I'm actually having some
ideas so
oh yeah H5 is um
ah5 is this is really cute now this is
strong look at this this is very strong
yeah because if he takes check
I'm getting
I'm getting in here really really
quickly very nice
so after this he has to drop back and
after this move I'm getting this this
pawn and H3 is also gone after that
great yeah that's a great move I didn't
see that I was only thinking about the
this Grand scale plan that I had
envisioned before with the Knight to H6
maybe it's not uh the most precise way
to play but um
I think it's it's very close to a win
what what this what should why do em
um it was the computer giving an
improvement somewhere now it's it's a
flat win right
F1 is better okay yeah though okay what
the computer wants to do it it wants to
protect this Pawn but okay this will
lose in the long run I mean I'm just
getting
here and then with the King and then I'm
going to push the pawn oh that's cute I
didn't want to do that
then I'm going to to push the air Pawn
so this is this is a very easy win okay
thanks for watching